la pierre laurin bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
alors la guerre des nerfs se poursuit
entre l'occident et la russie oh combien
de temps encore selon vous voilà on va
se retrouver dans cette impasse procès
avant cette crise l ukrainienne
c'est très difficile à dire dans la
mesure où chaque fois que il semble y
avoir une légère avancée dans le sens de
ce qu'on appelle une désescalade
d'une manière ou d'une autre la machine
est relancée en revient aux accusations
ou crainte
aux accusations réciproques mais
principalement dirigée par les états
unis et ses alliés les plus proches en
direction de la russie d'une certaine
manière on ne tient pratiquement pas
compte de ce que peut dire la russie est
également de la manière dont se présente
ce déploiement de troupes à la frontière
ont dit à la frontière mais c'est dans
la partie ouest de la russie voilà
tivement proches effectivement de la
frontière ukrainienne mais d'après les
services de renseignement
européens n'ont pas américain il n'y a
pas de l'indication
d'une éventuelle intervention d'une
éventuelle offensive rapide en ce sens
que les troupes ne sont pas positionnés
là où elle devrait être pour une peine
pour une attaque où il n'y a pas de
lignes de ravitaillement établi pour les
munitions l'approvisionnement en
munitions en carburant qui toujours
doivent précéder une attaque qu'il n'y a
pas de déploiement de deux hôpitaux de
campagne et c'est donc
les rues d'une certaine manière veulent
montrer que ils sont sur leur territoire
que ils ont une capacité
forte de pression mais qui ne compte pas
l'utiliser pour le moment du moins tant
que un processus de négociations et ne
sera pas véritablement ou engagées ou
refuser et c'est ce que dit depuis des
mois maintenant la diplomatie russe ce
qu'a réitérée le président vladimir
poutine au cours de sa conférence de
presse notamment avec le président
macron et dans cette configuration il
est difficile d'envisager une
désescalade tant que les deux parties
n'accepteront pas et particulièrement la
partie occidentale qui est celle qui
aujourd'hui met de la pression
n'accepterons pas de réduire les
attaques verbales la phraséologie et
revenir à des
essais relativement simple mais d'une
certaine manière ils ne veulent pas
revenir à une position beaucoup plus
modérée la russie qui n'est pas entendue
comme vous venez de le dire d'ailleurs
moscou a continué de retirer ces
continuent de retirer des chars qui sont
déployés à la frontière ukrainienne il
faut savoir que ces forces retournent
dans leurs garnisons après avoir terminé
un exercice d'entraînement qu'ils
étaient planifiés donc voilà tout ça a
été planifié bien à l'as vence les
etats-unis eux affirment le contraire on
le sait ils ont accusé plusieurs fois la
russie justement de vouloir envahir
l'ukraine quel est l'intérêt justement
des états unis de jeter de l'huile sur
le feu sans montrer de preuves
finalement de ce qu'ils avancent
l'intérêt en matière d intérêt multi le
premier intérêt est un intérêt d'image
d'image de marque de des états unis
après ce que l'on peut qualifier de
catastrophe en afghanistan le retrait
américain d'afghanistan a été réellement
une opération ratée non seulement raté
mais très contre-productives pour
l'image des états unis là les etats-unis
ont la possibilité de se redorer un peu
le blason à bon compte parce que
finalement des accusations verbal
n'engage pas c'est vrai qu'il y à une un
déploiement supplémentaire de troupes de
l'otan en europe mais par rapport à ce
qui existait déjà ce n'est pas
franchement significative donc dû s
d'une certaine manière les actes vont
dans un sens un peu
délicat mais pas trop mais d'un autre
côté le langage est résolument hostile
et je crois que
la deuxième raison pour les états unis
de d'avoir c'est ce langage c'est de
créer de continuer à créer ce qui est
utile pour l'otan c'est-à-dire un ennemi
sans la russie comme ennemi l'otan
devient inutile il n'y a pas de raison
d'avoir une organisation de défense
contre un ennemi inexistant donc il y
avait un livre très très très
intéressant de l'écrivain italien
umberto eco la création de l'ennemi pour
l'identité propre des individus il faut
qu'ils lisent à un adversaire et pour
les états c'est la même chose m c'est
même plus que
pour les individus les états ne vivent
que parce que ils sont entourés dans un
monde où il peut y avoir des éléments
d'hostilité et cette hostilité
extérieur créer la cohésion et la
cohésion de l'otan ne peut être créé que
par la montrent peu artificielle d'un
ennemi qui actuellement est la russie
dernière question très rapidement les
ministres des affaires étrangères du g7
de l'otan vont se retrouver à partir
d'aujourd'hui à munich pour la
conférence sur la sécurité en europe
berlin qu'il va dire donner le ton
puisque l'allemagne accuse la russie de
mettre en danger la sécurité de l'europe
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
déclaration
je crois que il y a toujours dans la
même perspective de la cohésion du monde
occidental il y à une sorte d'effet
d'entraînement les occidentaux dans leur
ensemble font
braquer contre la russie pour des
raisons que je viens d'expliquer en
revanche les européens voient la
situation
d'une manière un peu plus neutre
normalement que les américains et
d'ailleurs ça s'est vu lors des
conférences de presse du chancelier
choles et du président macro avec la
dîmière poutine ces derniers jours mais
la cohésion occidental à impose un
langage commun et en particulier lors de
cette conférence sur la sécurité qui
jadis était assez assez ouverte et qui
maintenant est très très restreinte aux
pays occidentaux qui vont être tous
sensiblement sur la même ligne parce que
diplomatiquement il est difficile de
faire autrement
merci beaucoup pierre laurin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
écrivain et spécialiste de la russie